nous avons abordé la question de
l'obligation vaccinale est bien entendu
le ministre nous a répondu que cette
question fera partie de la négociation
est bien évidemment nous conseille une
radio stick
l'obligation vaccinale
on va rediscuter et cela il faut à
partir des négociations je répète encore
une fois et puis la question de
continuité des services donc par
conséquent nous estimons aujourd'hui que
nous allons retourner à la table de
négociations pour discuter de ces sujets
là et nous voulons rassurer en tout cas
normandin et la population que ce qui
faisait débat aujourd'hui le ministre a
bien compris que notre spécificité
doivent être prises en compte dans cette
question d'obligation vaccinale vous
savez très bien que moi même que et le
compliqué pour un ministre de femmes ans
et de prononcer d'assonancés aujourd'hui
comme ça faisait grand beau génois ce
n'est pas possible nous sommes réalistes
mais nous sommes aussi dans la logique
où la population à une faute je dirais
pourcentage des pas vaccinés et nous
savons aussi que lille sera
difficilement possible de reclasser
3000 personnes c'est de ça qu'il s'agit
aussi la joute par conséquent nous
pouvons dire aujourd'hui nous attendons
la
la poursuite en tout cas des discussions
en ateliers et j'aime pas tellement
naturel et la possible de discussions
entre les partenaires sociaux et l'état
et bien entendu nous allons faire ce
qu'il faut faire dans l'intérêt bien
compris de la martinique janet c est
bien compris de toute la population